hello everyone and welcome to a very
special game from the world Blitz
Championship that happened a few days
ago it is around 16 and it is on smoking
Iman versus very strong Georgian
Grandmaster Giga kuparate and I've had a
chance to go over the games and uh some
of them were more interesting some of
them were less interesting and there are
so many of them it's really impossible
to choose but this game if you've liked
the the Carlson Rapport game then this
game I think it's even crazier than that
one like so many twists and turns uh if
you haven't seen the game there is no
way you guess who actually wins this
game or if anyone wins it now let's dive
straight into it the game is over a
hundred moves but we can easily divided
the game in three parts I don't mean the
opening the middle game in the end game
but uh you'll see what I mean by this so
uh Hans has the white pieces and he
opens with D4 we have Knight F6 C4 E6
Knight to F3 going for the antonyms of
variation and now still Bishop to B4
check the BOGO Indian defense Knight bd2
B6 we have A3 and Bishop captures on D2
this is the main line uh we have Bishop
captures and now Bishop to B7 uh we have
G3 white also released the fianca to the
light Revolution we have castles Bishop
to G to end the D6 so far all standard
Theory we have castles Knight B to D7
Rook to C1 and now A5 stopping an
immediate B4 action and there is a game
that actually reached this position from
1997 but they decided to call it a draw
here and here uh Hans plays Queen to C2
and it is now as of move 11 that we have
a completely new game
okay Giga says let's go after that Queen
Bishop to E4 like I said this is Blitz
three plus two and for the most part of
the game players will be playing an
increment uh that will explain a lot of
the moves with Queen to C3 Queen to E7
and now Rook fte1 just putting pieces on
optimal squares C5 uh Giga strikes in
the center and now Hans strikes would be
four we have eight characters a captures
and pawn to H6 rooked A1 uh opposing uh
uh the black Rook on A8 Rook F the C8
and now D captures on C5 we have D
captures on C5 and Hans grabs more space
with Pawn to B5 uh having ideas of maybe
putting the Rook on A6 so E5 and now
Bishop to H3 yeah pinning that Knight so
Rook to d8 and now Rook captures an A8
Rook captures and now Rook to A1 so just
trading all the Rooks along the a file
Road captures Queen characters and now
we have Queen to D6 putting pressure on
that uh up on D2 so the immediate threat
of Bishop captures on F3 and that's it
white will resign so Bishop to C3 and
now we have Bishop captures on F3 e
characters and queen D3 putting pressure
on the F3 pawn and the C4 paw on the C4
Pawn on the bishop if the queen moves so
black queen is incredibly active and the
Hans uh has a couple of options here he
can play Bishop capture Sun E5 he can
play Bishop captures on D7 he can even
play F4 you know he he goes for bashup
characters on E5 let's trade everything
Queen captures on C4 and now
uh C4 Pawn uh is uh capturing the C4
Pawn is a terrible move because now Hans
just plays Queen to A8 with check
Knights the f8 and Bishop to D6
threatening Queen characters Knight here
and you cannot play uh Knight to D7
because Bishop just gobbles it up so you
have to bring the Knight all the way to
H7 and now a nice idea for Hans would be
Bishop F1 attacks the queen defense the
B5 pawn and then you go after the B6
Pawn create a pass B Pawn and win the
game that way but okay like I said uh
it's it's Blitz Queen to E8 by Hans and
now we have Queen to D4 uh putting
pressure on the bishop here uh Queen to
C6 defending the bishop and attacking
the B6 pawn and now a c for Giga now
starts advancing his pass Pawn we have
F4 by Hans and now Pawn to C3 with
Bishop to F5 and now Pawn to G6 with
Bishop to C2 and now Queen to D2
attacking the bishop here but just
Bishop to B3 and the bishop is a
spectacular piece on B3
um controlling this down signal and also
the queen and Bishop control the C2
Square so I don't have to worry about
the black advancing that past Pawn we
have Knight to F6 and now hunt plays
Bishop captures on f8 a knight to F6
um doesn't really work because it just
leaves the Knight hanging but like I
said three three minute Blitz Bishop
captures on f8 and now of course Hans is
completely winning he just won a piece
and uh there's really nothing for you to
do if you capture an f8 uh just Queen
captures on F2 and if you want the C2
Queen captures on F7 is Checkmate it's
as simple as that so the black does not
have any compensation for the sacrifice
piece here so Queen to D4 Giga doesn't
resign Giga continues fighting Queen to
C7 Now by Hans going for checkmate Here
and Now Knight to D5 and what's the idea
here Knight to D5 seems like such a
terrible move you're just gonna capture
the Knight and after Queen captures
you're gonna move the bishop probably
Bishop captures on H6 hunts will be up
up a piece and in a completely winning
position and while that's true you have
to play something like queen to d8 queen
to d8 and black resides you are now
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries the Knight is attacked twice
there is no playing this uh but instead
even if you or even if Knight captures
an F4 hoping for some uh Queen captures
92 check winning the queen action here
he will still just play Bishop to D6
with checking G7 and you will pick up
the Knight here and now you're gonna be
up two pieces however in the game after
Knight the D5 Hans fell for the Trap he
played Bishop captures on D5 and now
Giga doesn't just capture the bishop he
wants to capture the bishop with Tempo
so he plays Queen to D1 check this is
what Hans missed King G2 now Queen
captures on D5 with check King to H3 and
now you could pick up the bishop right
away but he throws in a few more checks
Queen H5 checking G2 Queen into D5
checking to H3 and now King captures an
f8 and okay Hans blunder the piece Queen
captures on C3 Queen captures on B5 and
we have this queen and pawn end game
with equal material however hunts with
the pad with the doubled F Pawn and a
giga with the past B Pawn so black will
be the one pushing for the win here Hans
uh Hans knows his only chance is to open
up the black King's position and make
him prone to some some checkings uh G4
King to G8 and now Queen to C8 with
check now you have to play really really
quickly there especially Hans Hans was
down to like three seconds for the for
the rest of the game and he's basically
playing an increment King to H7 Queen to
C7 now going for the F7 pawn queen to B3
with check now black uh all that black
needs to do is figure out how to start
advancing the past B Pawn and he does
King to G2 with uh B5 now comes Queen to
E5 and now Pawn to B4 we have pawned the
F5 hunts wants to open up the black
talking Queen to see for now getting
ready to continue advancing the past
beep on F captures on G6 and now King
captures on G6 the only winning move for
Giga if he plays the F chapters then his
King will be Boxed In by his own pawns
here so here Queen to F5 checking G7 and
queen to E5 with check we have King to
G8 and now Pawn to G5 uh you have to do
this now we have Queen to C6 check F3
and now H captures on G5 and this sort
of allows Hans to get back into the game
but he has to play Queen to B8 with
check the reason why he missed this Hans
wanted to play Queen captures on G5 with
check but then he saw if Queen captures
on G5 Queen G6 blocks check forces a
queen trade and now white king will not
be in time to stop the black pawn
captures captures you are a way way
outside the square of the Pont uh that
actually stop the pawn so Hans played
King F2 he prepares this even though
this could have just won him the B Pawn
but uh increment and now Queen the C2
with check King to G3 Queen to D2 now
guarding all of the pawns so uh still
making ready to start advancing the past
B Pawn Queen E8 check King to G7 Queen
to E5 check into G6 Queen E4 check King
the H6 and now Queen to E8 going after
the F Pawn Queen to F for checking to G2
and King back to G7 we have Queen to B5
uh not allowing the pass b-pawn to be
pushed and also putting pressure on the
g-pawn so Queen to D2 check we have a
few repetitions here Queen G3 Queen to
D6 checking to G2 King to G6 and now
Queen to C4 again making sure nothing is
being pushed we have Queen to D2 with
check King to G1 and now Queen to F4
offering a queen trade Queen to C6 of
course Hans declines this King to G7 and
now Queen to B7 again positioning the
queen behind the pass b-pawn Queen to C4
uh sorry uh Queen to C4 and now Queen to
E7 we have Queen to D4 with check King
to G2 now Queen to detail with King H3
and now Queen uh and and now finally
Pawn to B3 and here we have Queen to E5
with check and Giga has to play King H7
or King to G6 those are the two moves
that that are good for him however he
plays King the G8 and even though he
missed Queen to ba to check for the
first time and Hans also missed it now
Hans spots it but interestingly Hans
picks up the queen and he brings the
queen over to Eid but he doesn't drop
the queen he spots Queen to B8 and then
he just re-maneuvers Queen back to E5 to
B8 it was like a really wild hand
maneuver if you haven't seen the video
do check it out so here he wins the B
Pawn and now Giga is no longer winning
King G7 Queen captures on B3 two pawns
each uh Hans uh Hans has uh two isolated
pawns and Giga with the two connected
pawns with Queen to F2
uh Queen to C3 check now we have Pawn to
F6 and now Queen to C7 with check King
G6 Queen to C6 and now Queen to F1 with
check King to G3 Queen to G1 with
checking the H3 Queen F1 check and here
just uh when you thought that you will
see a repetition here and that the
players will call it a day King to G3
Queen to E1 check Giga continues playing
King to G2 Queen to E2 check King to G3
Queen to E5 with check King G2 and now
King back to G7 now Hans starts checking
Queen B7 checking to G6 Queen to C8 and
now Queen to E2
again with check with King to G3 and
queen to E1 with check King to G2 Queen
to E2 check King to H G3 and queen to E5
check King to G2 and King to G7 now we
have Queen to D7 with check by Hans
kinta H6 uh and now Queen to C8 uh
keeping the the the the the possibility
of some back rank checks uh we have
Ponta F5 and now we have Queen to C6
with check King to H5 Queen to C2 and
now we have King the H4 so uh very very
close to the white king but there's not
all that much you can do here Queen to
F2 with check King H5 and now Queen back
to A2 not allowing any checks along the
second rank uh Queen to E7 and now Queen
to C2 both players just playing moves
really fast to gain more time on
increment Queen to D7 Queen to B2 and
now King to G6 with Queen to B6 with
check uh King to H5 and now Queen back
to B2 we have queen to d8 queen to C2
and now Queen to D5 uh we have Queen to
B2 and now Pawn to G4 finally upon move
we have Queen to h8 with check King to
G6 and now Queen to E8 with check King
H6 Queen E3 check King to G7 and now
King to G3 luckily you don't have to
worry about a move like F4 but even
though even if F4 was played this is
still a draw however in the game Queen
D6 check and now Hans plays Pawn to F4
and this makes the F5 Pawn a little bit
weak we have Queen to C6 and now pretty
much any move except Queen to C6 will
continue the game as a draw but this
just gives Hans too many uh squares to
go after the F5 Pawn now Hans plays
Queen to E7 with check and there's no
way to avoid the loss of the df5 pawn if
you move the king to h8 then Queen f8
check picks up the pawns and now in the
game Queen to G6 was played but now
Queen to G5 check was played then s Hans
played this there was there was such a
huge grin on his face he could not
believe that he went from a winning
position to a completely lost position
to now again a winning position
King F7 and now he picks up the pawns
with checks Queen captures on F5 King G7
Queen captures and G4 with check King F7
and now he's up two pawns from being
down upon and in a completely lost game
he now all he has to do is Advance his
Pawn to Victory that's pretty much it
and avoid a few checks along the way and
he does exactly that Queen F5 check King
to G7 H for now Queen to C3 with check
King to G4 the pawns are now marching
forward and queen to C1 giga's last hope
is to get some sort of a Perpetual maybe
start checking the the white king from
behind but just Queen the E5 check King
to F7 and now we reach a position where
pretty much every move every and any
move is winning for Hans uh and when I
said it I don't mean moves like Queen to
B2 of course we're not discussing that
but any move is winning for for white
except the move that Hans played Hans
played King to G5 it makes sense he
wants to start checking the the black
king he wants to further Advance the
pawns he won the white king to maybe
assisted the White Queen in checkmating
the black king however now he is getting
checkmated it's actually a force to
Checkmate in two so feel free to pause
the video and try to find the winning
idea uh for Giga while I give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting that
every Square uh the white king gets
checkmated and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Queen to G1
check that's it this is what Giga played
Hans played King the H5 uh and here he
or maybe he didn't maybe after I'm just
gonna check uh I don't want to trick you
guys uh no after Queen to G1 check it
was in this position uh unmove what's
the 113 that Hans Neiman resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here the problem is King the H6 or H5
run into the exact same idea King H6
just Queen to G6 Checkmate and if you go
to F5 which is probably what Hans was
hoping for even if Queen to G1 check
happens on the board now look at this
queen and pawn you know this position
and now Queen to G6 will be Checkmate
absolutely spectacular Hans saw this and
uh interestingly he had the the exact
same green on his face when he saw that
he would win the the two points and then
he would have two past pawns he had the
same grin now when he spotted that he
blundered into Checkmate and it's not
that spectacular King G5 is now a force
Checkmate in two yeah so really it will
tell it's incredible that you can like
stumble into this when you're when
you're the one pushing for the win when
you are the one being up two points your
opponent doesn't have any anything just
a queen and a king you have a queen and
two past pawns and still uh you know
it's possible to happen chess is cruel
Blitz chest is even more cruel uh it
happens to everyone and here it happened
to the Hans Queen G1 check Hans resigned
as uh there is no way to avoid Checkmate
so really spectacular stuff uh Hans
outplayed Giga Giga allowed that uh
funny stuff on the back rank then hunt
was completely winning then Hans
blundered a piece uh then uh Hans
equalize then Hans blunder the pawn then
Giga was completely winning pushing his
past Pawn then hunts again equalized and
then Giga blundered Hans had the two
pass Pawns and then hunts blunders a
mating too that's chess that's why we
enjoy chess and uh well it's just so
much so much and nicer when it happens
to other people and not us but yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
and thank you for suggesting such a wild
game I know it's 113 moves but what what
a game no way if you haven't seen the
this game you guessed who will win it
watching this uh so I once again hope
you enjoyed it I will uh I would like to
thank James Mayberry mate
Weaver Sky music and Ben Benjamin for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions such as this
one and whatever else happens in the
Chess World thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day